- [Voiceover] When we look at
all of the living diversity
around us,
then a natural question is,
well, how related are the
difference species to each other?
And if you put that into
an evolutionary context,
relatedness should be tied to
how recent did two species
share a common ancestor.
And what we're going to
try to do in this video
is construct a tree for
showing how different species
evolved from common ancestors,
and we're gonna do it
based on some of these
observable traits that we see.
But this is going to be a
huge oversimplification.
I'm only doing it with five species
and five very simple traits.
As we'll see, or as we'll
talk about in future videos,
this can be done in a
much more complex way,
and that's what biologists would do.
They would look at much
more than five traits,
and they would look at molecular evidence,
molecular evidence in terms
of protein differences,
in terms of DNA differences,
to really start to build out
what we call a phylogenetic tree.
So let me write this down.
That's what we're going to create.
Phylogenetic,
genetic,
tree.
Phylo comes from the Greek
for group or kind or tribe,
and then genetic comes, you know,
related to the word "genesis."
How do these things come about?
How do the different groups or tribes,
or in this case, how do the
different species come about?
Well, when you're trying
to make one of these trees,
it's important to realize
that this is a hypothesis,
but you're, like always,
trying to come up with
the simplest hypothesis
that can explain the observations
that you actually see.
And when we look at these,
at least the species
that we have listed here,
it looks like there's one
that is more different
than all the other ones.
The lamprey here does not
have any of these five traits
that we are observing.
So this, we would call the out group.
The lamprey is the outgroup.
And a lot of times
when you need to construct
a phylogenetic tree,
they might provide you something,
with something that is
clearly an outgroup.
Here it doesn't have any
of these observable traits.
And sometimes, if we're
looking at genetic differences,
it might have the largest
number of genetic differences
relative to everything else.
And so it makes sense,
the simplest hypothesis
is its common ancestor
is most distant into the
past with everything else.
And so let me start to draw this tree.
So I'm going to put deep into the past,
so deep into the past, there
is a branching out point
where you have the common
ancestor of the lamprey
and everything else we see here.
So eventually, you have
that common ancestor,
and there's many, many
species along the way,
and eventually, we get,
we get a lamprey in present time.
In present time.
And so the next thing to
think about is, alright,
well how did everything
else end up branching?
Well, what's common about everything else
that maybe wasn't common
about the lamprey?
Well, one common thing is
we see that everything else,
at least that we have
listed here, have jaws.
And so it's reasonable to say, alright,
we have this common ancestor,
between the lamprey and everything else
at this branching point right over here,
and then it branched off
into multiple species,
and one of those species
must have evolved jaws.
So let me put jaws right over here.
So jaws right over there.
And jaws, that's called,
jaws are considered a derived trait.
This ancestral species at
this root did not have jaws,
we're assuming,
but at some point, they
evolved, and they stuck around
because they proved to be
favorable in certain environments.
Or it could have even been
things like genetic drift,
who knows, but I'm guessing
that it was favorable
in certain environments.
So let's see, let's see if we
can classify everyone else.
So now, out of the four, so we've,
let's actually cross out the lamprey
just for simplification
since we've already
classified that character.
Now of everyone else,
we've already thought
about everyone's got jaws,
so now let's go to the
next most common trait.
So, and actually, let me
cross out the jaws too,
just for, keep things simple.
So we can do that a little bit cleaner.
So I'm gonna cross out the jaws.
And now, let's see,
the next most common trait are the lungs,
but not every species that
we have left has lungs.
The sea bass does not have lungs.
It does not breathe air
the way that animals
that live outside of
the water breathe air.
And so the next point of divergence
must be between the sea bass
and everything that we have left over.
So let me draw that.
So,
now once again, I said, "must be."
This is a hypothesis.
I think it's a reasonable hypothesis.
So let me draw that.
So
this is the sea,
sea bass.
And there's a common
ancestor between the sea bass
and everything else, and the antelope,
the bald eagle, and the alligator.
And at some point, that
common ancestor diverged
into multiple species,
and one of those child species
must have evolved lungs.
So lungs must have evolved at some point,
but we're assuming that
that wasn't on this lineage
for the sea bass.
And once again,
I'm just trying to find
the simplest explanation.
There might have been some situation where
maybe lungs evolved and then
went away at some point.
You reverted to an ancestral form.
But we like to go with
the simplest explanation.
This is a property that
biologists will also often call
parsimony, and actually,
let me write this down.
Parsimony, which in everyday
language, means cheap.
When someone tells you
that you're parsimonious,
it's a nice sounding word, but
it means that you are cheap.
But parsimony, in this context,
say hey, we're trying to
be cheap with complexity.
We're trying to be as simple as possible
in our explanation of what's going on.
But anyway, let's go back
to what we were doing.
So we've already put into consideration,
we have already talked
about the sea bass here,
and we have already talked about lungs.
Alright, so what do we have left?
So we have to talk about the antelope,
the bald eagle, the alligator,
and gizzards and fur.
Alright, it looks like the
bald eagle and alligator
have a gizzard.
The antelope has fur,
oh and actually, we haven't talked about
the bald eagle and
feathers as yet, either.
Alright, so it is possible.
So let's make the next thing between,
well, we could do it this way.
And once again, I'm trying
to do this in real time,
something that seems,
so let's make a branch here.
And let's say that that is the branch for,
now let's say that's the
branch for the bald eagle.
Say, "B. Eagle."
That's the branch for the bald eagle,
and let's see if I can construct one
that will explain the differences
between the bald eagle,
the antelope, and the alligator.
Well, the bald eagle and the alligator
have something in common.
They have a gizzard in common.
So let me make a branching point.
Make them a little bit closer
than the bald eagle is to the antelope.
So let me do that.
So let me put the alligator there,
and then I'm gonna talk about
when we get these derived traits.
So that is
the alligator.
And obviously, I could
have written the alligator
on this side and the
bald eagle on that side,
or I could've rotated,
I could rotate at any one
of these branching points.
And then what we would
have left is the antelope.
Now let's see if I can account
for all of these derived traits.
Antelope.
Alright.
So we have the common
ancestor of the sea bass,
the bald eagle, the alligator,
and antelope right over here.
We have a branching point.
At some point, the lungs,
we're hypothesizing
evolved in this branch.
And then this branch,
well let's say that this branch,
this is the common ancestor
between the antelope,
alligator, and bald eagle.
And a common ancestor of the
bald eagle and alligator,
they have to get the gizzard.
So let's put the gizzard
down right over here.
This is where the gizzard,
this is our hypothesis.
Doing the same color as,
so that's the gizzard.
Gizzard
right over there.
And so everything that
descended from that ancestor
that had the gizzard,
well, they're going to have gizzards.
That's what we're assuming,
but once again, that can be lost.
This is a hypothesis.
And so we have accounted for the gizzard.
Let me,
let me cross that out.
So we have accounted for the gizzard.
And so let's see,
we have to account for the feathers,
and the bald eagle is the
only one that has feathers.
So let me put that here.
So at some point, you
have a common ancestor
of an alligator and a bald eagle.
It branches off into multiple species,
one of which gets a
feather or gets feathers.
And once again, you know,
that could have branched off
into many, many things,
'cause we know that the bald eagle
isn't the only species with feathers.
But the bald eagle, for sure,
is a species that has feathers.
And let's see, so we've
accounted for the feathers now.
Feathers.
And now, we just have
to account for the fur,
the fur of the antelope.
And so, we don't know where
this could have happened.
We might wanna look for more evidence
to come up with a good hypothesis.
But some place along this right branch,
we could put,
we could put the fur.
And so there you have it.
This is actually a
reasonable phylogenetic tree.
I practiced the practice of parsimony
to come up with the simplest explanation,
but there are more
complicated explanations.
And we don't know,
some of those more
complicated explanations
could very well be true.
But from this,
we have a very quick and
easy graphical representation
of how related different species could be
and where they share common ancestors.
So bald eagle and an alligator,
based on this phylogenetic tree,
we would say are more related
than a bald eagle is to an antelope.
They have a more, the bald
eagle and the alligator,
have a more common common ancestor,
or more recent common ancestor right there
than both of their common
ancestors with the antelope,
and that would make them more related.
And if we were doing this for real,
we would wanna look at genetic evidence
and look at the various proteins
and say, okay, does that back this up?
Are the bald eagle and alligator's DNA,
do they have more in
common with each other
than they do with the
DNA, say, of an antelope?
And many, for especially
once you get complex,
there could be many
different explanations,
and we just wanna get more
and more and more evidence
to keep refining our phylogenetic trees.